tonga was cut off from the rest of the
world when the disaster struck a
submarine fiber optic cable was severed
and will take at least four weeks to
repair
in the meantime some satellite phone and
internet connections have been set up
allowing more footage to emerge of the
devastation caused by the volcano and
tsunami
for some family in new zealand the
slight improvement in communication has
come as a relief even though everything
parts of the
houses
it's been washed away the crops
but
we hear that our family and our friends
are well
at the moment in tonga
others anxiously wait for news while
they prepare their own aid packages to
send home amid so much uncertainty the
pacific island community in new zealand
is coming together to help the people of
tonga and with ash on the ground and
contaminating the water supply this has
become a precious commodity and will
soon be on its way to tonga
the first government aid has finally
arrived in auckland a new zealand air
force plane was loaded with supplies
before departing for the international
airport just outside the capital nuku
alofa where it stayed on the ground for
just 90 minutes
the australian military also deployed
following confirmation that the runway
had been cleared of ash and was safe to
land on
the priorities from the
tongan government are what we're really
working to and primarily in the first
instance the provision of clean water
that that's the key priority that the
tongan government has asked for there
are around 80 000 tongans in new zealand
most of whom would have strong family
ties to their homeland but have probably
never felt so far away wayne hey al
jazeera auckland